anyway enough about scams i'm going to
hijack this podcast for a moment turn it
back into an anime podcast what
because i i just i i i need to i just i
just need to okay
i just i just i just i i just just let
me have this let me have this corner let
me have this because i uh i know exactly
what you're gonna talk about
of course you do i don't of course you
do joey so this weekend i watched the
new uh evangelical movie
and i just i i did not see this coming
connor he was literally tweeting about
it all week i i need to talk about this
because i can't i need to move on with
mine this man this man's tweeted about
it like he watched like 13 reasons why
for the first time i'm glad i'm glad
though we finally watched it because
again i i watched it on the day it came
out in the cinemas which was like
[ __ ] six months ago or something it
was a really really long time ago and i
was like i want to talk about it so bad
on the podcast but these two haven't
seen it so i'm just gonna like i'm just
gonna bottle this emotion up and now i
can
like like it's like witnessing the death
of a family member you know it's like
it's like actually mortifying i'm like
oh my god so yeah it's no more good or
bad kind of death like it's a weird
cousin that you didn't really like okay
i don't know how to like
possibly convey the feeling i felt but
what i will say is that i mean like i
shouldn't have just i shouldn't have
ever been a monk at all right that was
that was like that was a [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] scam because if i wanted
to feel zen if i wanted to reach nevada
i should have i should have just been an
ava fan right because i fell more zen
after the end of eva after this end of
favor than i ever did as a monk was it
that good it was uh it's it's like it's
the type of movie that you can't just
clean
it's the type of movie that you can't
just clean up with the word good yeah or
bad yeah because it's neither of those
it's just like that sounds like it's
mediocre
definitely not mediocre anything it's
not mediocre yeah
it is the polar opposite of mediocre
yeah i saw the imdb page the reviews
were kind of you know all over the place
yeah yeah seven eight it's around about
seven eight it's like i think the only
way i can describe that last movie is do
you have to have a very iq to understand
afa
it's very difficult to figure out that
that's full if you can't perform
rudimentary mathematics then you just
not all even allowed you watched the
original ao when it got released on
netflix right yeah i did what what was
your opinions of the tv
yeah
seven out of ten
it was fine i you know i i i i
understand why everyone is so hyped
about it yeah yeah um did i just
i could see why you'd watch this and you
would remember this yeah yeah but i
didn't think it was that amazing right
yeah i think i think that's like i i
think that's the comment
it leaves an impression yeah i think
i'll say that much yeah and you can't
you know it's this isn't like
the irregular high school whatever the
[ __ ] that one is where you're like
you're like i literally don't even know
who you are and i'm 20 episodes into
this like
there's four seasons of that [ __ ] as
well yeah yeah yeah i mean i don't even
know that yeah
there's like a spin-off coming this
season as well and it's like it's yeah
you know it's one of those shows that
definitely was like i understand
entirely why this is iconic and everyone
is in love with this yeah i just
personally wasn't that into it did you
did you leave satisfied no not at all
okay good good yes because i was like
because that was my experience that was
the worst part yeah
let me ask you then did you leave
satisfied uh with the original waiver no
no with 4.0 oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
tv series
it was [ __ ] the tv series left everyone
unsatisfied i mean i mean like i
remember the first two times i watched
ava i [ __ ] hated it yeah yeah michael
because the first time i watched it i
was 12. of course i was
of course i was not going to understand
ava when i was 12 and then i re-watched
it not enough iq yeah i re-watched it to
review it as an annie tuber and then i
was just like this is even worse than i
remember it right because now i now i'm
actually invested in the characters in
the world and the mysteries that you
actually understand it sort of
felt like a slap in the face yeah yeah
yeah
someone who of course yeah all day
watching it i just what did i end up
with applause and congratulations let's
see
is this it yeah
it's like the show was mocking me like
congratulations you sat through all of
this for nothing yeah so they could what
milk foot like another 50 years out of
this of movies
was five head in there yeah yeah yeah he
was planning ahead he was [ __ ] five
minutes and then i remember i remember
going on the internet [ __ ] angry and
i'm just like surely that can't be the
ending and then people were just like yo
have you heard of this movie called
the favor end of evangelion which is the
end of it which which is uh
i mean it is and end of april
uh whether you are satisfied with that
and the alternative ending one
yeah it's alternative but it's also
canon
yeah so so
so kind of kind of the history behind
the first two
the the the tv series ending is that as
you could probably tell the uh studio
just kind of ran out of money and ran
out of like budget so they had to like
piece together something right
um and so that was the ending that you
saw and so either like either fans were
so unsatisfied that they sent anno and
the
company death threats or anna himself
was unsatisfied with the ending that he
decided to make a bunch of clapping
let's just it's hard yeah let's make
let's make another ending to ava and
that's the end of the van gaalion and
people were just like all right i'm
ready now this is this is this is the
ending that's we never got it's finally
the title of the movie it's called end
of ever and that's not even the ending
right that's what i understand it's a
ending
it's it's definitely a ending but it
definitely doesn't
leave you satisfied what's the one short
of
even going what order one no no
tv show then movies
okay so 1.0 uh is basically the first
i'd say 15 episodes right there's an
abridged movie yeah it's basically just
like a cliff notes version of the tv
series and then 2.0 the first half of
2.0 it approaches the original ending of
the tv series but then goes on a
different that's [ __ ] cheeky that
yeah yeah yeah so
this is this ad in theaters
it's cheeky [ __ ]
made one third of a movie and called it
a day pretty much yeah oh my god maybe i
should just make [ __ ] things and
re-release them again in future and add
another 20 so basically there's the
second half of 2.0 uh and you know mind
you i don't fully remember everything
because it was a while since i watched
it but i do i'm pretty sure
all right so i'm talking to someone who
literally knows every frame of the first
movie because i [ __ ] abridged it
so so like 1.0 is basically just almost
a shot for shot recreation of like the
first
four or five episodes and then with
cleaner art yeah with cleaner arts and
uh minor minor minor differences then
2.0 like it's still like very very
similar to like episodes maybe like six
to 18 ish for [ __ ] sake yeah i mean
it's it's it it goes it has other
differences it introduces a new
character which is the girl of glasses
and it has other like minor differences
but for the most part it's pretty much
the same and then i feel like
introducing a whole new character is not
the same i mean you're doing the same
until you introduce the characters yeah
yeah it's the same until you introduce
her and then 3.0 and 4.0 which i'm going
to go which i'm going to call 4.0
because three plus one is four
yeah it's it is dumb it is it's an
[ __ ] called no hideyaki
three
3.0 and 4.0 are like completely
different so it's like almost like a
that's completely original yeah it's
it's like the first time you walk you
walked into starbucks and realized it
was not medium small and large yeah why
why did you do this so which one venti
which one's
i still don't know what a [ __ ] venti
is i i still don't understand no the
part that [ __ ] me up was like tall is
not large yeah yeah yeah tall is medium
tallest medium
this is why i just like the chart i can
see the price that's how i do yeah yeah
yeah anyway sorry go on back to the 4.0
yeah so anyway so 3.0 and 4.0 are
completely original yeah um so i watched
so okay so i watched 3.0 on the day it
came out in cinemas i was 16 when that
came out okay
so it was literally 10 years ago and i
only seen it once yeah so imagine me
going to the cinemas day one airing of
4.0 right and i'm like
and i was like i got this
i still remember you you don't got this
i don't i was like i don't got this
because
literally the first five minutes of 4.0
it does a recap and i'm like oh thank
god that's great because there's a 10
year gap right yeah so it goes through
like super fast like super artistic way
of just being like here's what happened
to 1.0 here's what happened 2.0 here's
what happened 3.0 goes through 1.0 i'm
like okay yeah this is just the tv
series i've seen tv series many times
got it in the bag 2.0 i was like okay
yep still the tv series but introduce
the new character all right cool yeah
3.0 i'm just like
i don't remember any of that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on and then 4.0
just begins and i was like
cool
so i'm literally going into this movie
with maybe about
a five percent understanding of what has
happened so far it's it's it's all good
man because i don't think that would
have helped you at all um because the
reason i didn't i chose not to see it in
cinemas right was because obviously it
wasn't subbed it was in japanese
with a series like ava i wanted to at
least try to understand what was going
on yeah because i did i did remember
what happened in 3.0 so i was like i
remember most of the plot points so i'll
be able to follow along easily um so
finally i waited for it to come out and
i was just like i should have just seen
this in theaters because i have as much
of an understanding of what's going on
in my own language than i do in a
[ __ ] other language that i'm like
barely understand
for me 4.0 was like all right cool
that's a line i understood what they
were saying i think i'm starting to get
it and then literally the next line i'm
like i don't understand what's going on
and i'm like this is a language i am
fluent this is my first language that
they're speaking in it sounds like a
different language there's just so much
terminology being thrown around which
yeah i'm sure there was some kind of
explanation of probably in 3.0 yeah but
of course i have a 10-year gap with 3.0
obviously i don't remember that [ __ ] the
definitive way to watch it is to watch
three and immediately immediately start
fall
probably i don't think it even matters
because i i don't remember
i doubt a lot of people are going to be
able to follow along in their first
watch through anyway because so much
terminology gets [ __ ] thrown around
and just gets like pulled out of his ass
like like some some of the scenes i'm
just like i know i don't know if you're
a genius or a madman like
oh yeah and then here's the more [ __ ]
up thing that i realized if there's
anything i got out of 4.0 it's the fact
that there is literally information in
4.0 you will have no idea what the [ __ ]
it is unless you read the manga yeah
yeah i was like literally took every
iteration it was like it took bits from
the tv series it took bits from end of
aver it took even little bits from death
and rebirth yeah and the manga and just
combined it all together so it's like if
you're missing
that's the other movie
yeah it's it's just basically a recap
movie yeah it's a recap movie but
there's like small minor details in
death and rebirth that are only specific
to death and reboot but like i have like
for someone like you i wouldn't even
recommend watching exhausted hearing
aids you don't have to watch definitely
yeah yeah yeah i mean i've watched two
three and four
yeah i mean if and if and available if
you feel like yeah because i tried to
watch ender
uh
you you do like if if you wanted to get
to get into end of a uh in get into
evangelion as a franchise then yeah you
need to watch end of ava yeah but like i
mean it depends on it depends on what
you're looking for because if you're
just looking for like a normal tv series
a normal story to get like entertained
so much so where you know you're looking
for like a normal plot arc you're
looking for mysteries to be solved
that's just not going to happen as
you've just experienced once i think
what's so special about ava is that it's
a series that's just so powerful that
if you kind of relate to what anno was
trying to portray on screen like you
said yourself you could tell why a lot
of people thought this like a lot of
people saw this as like a really
powerful series that affected them right
and it's just because it is just that
raw and powerful because ava to me ava
like i didn't get ava the first few
times i watched it like i said i was
like i [ __ ] hated that yeah and then
like i reached later i reached a period
in life later where i started to like
[ __ ] resonate more with what was
being portrayed on screen i wouldn't say
i understood the entire plot but i don't
think that's the point of favor i don't
think the point of favor is to
understand the plot i don't think the
point of ava is to like you know you
can't just look at the shiny robots
fighting the big monsters if you want
but i think
i think the true magic of favor was just
anno pouring his heart out on screen and
capturing like it's kind of like
capturing his psyche in a sense yeah and
that's why it's like that's why you can
view it and this and you can just be
like i don't get it this is a complete
[ __ ] mindfuck which it is it is an
absolutely yeah i truly think especially
with 4.0 i truly think the only person
on the planet who can fully understand
4.0 and all of eva is anna yeah because
there's probably working on the movie
they're like no what is it
4.0 i feel especially 4.0 is like a true
not only is it like a true love letter
to ava but there's so much stuff that
arnold just crammed into it that really
has nothing to do with ava it's
literally like he just threw it in
because he likes it yeah and i feel
that's what ava is it's it's like it's
literally a series that anna was like i
like robots i like monsters i like kaiju
fights i love all of this [ __ ] that i
personally enjoy i'm gonna cram this
[ __ ] into one series and that's ava
yeah cause like you like you like bojack
right yeah i still haven't watched the
last season i'm too scared yeah because
i i feel like bojack is probably the
closest kind of like closest big
american show that i can compare to avoc
because both
[Laughter]
was like
i guess bojack was very clear in what it
was trying to portray yeah i guess i was
slightly confused many times during eva
i'm like yeah am i supposed to feel
sorry for shinji
well that's a
yeah because i both are the kind of same
with what they tried to tackle they
tried to tackle broken characters trying
to just find value in themselves and
just live with themselves right that's
that's that's what both series tried to
do bojack has a much more structured you
know much more structured story much
more defined character arcs and it's
just easier to follow and less technical
[ __ ] i felt like you know you in
bojack you got to like see
why he was so [ __ ] up and i felt like
in evangelion we didn't really learn
much about shinji
and he was just whining i definitely
feel like i don't i mean i think the
finer details are there if for people
who want to look into a deeper but i
feel especially the movies do a really
good job in portraying shinji as this
like broken kid yeah because i mean he's
a 14 year old kid who has like massive
daddy issues because his dad's an
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] he never grew
up with his mom um is forced to pilot a
[ __ ] giant robot at the age of 14 and
has to say
sad about this
normally i mean i mean i'm not gonna
obviously not gonna see any spoils for
4.0 but yeah especially in 4.0 his dad
is [ __ ] yeah
he's like i didn't think his dad could
get even more [ __ ] yeah oh my god you
know it's like it goes from like one to
a hundred i'm like
you cannot be seen yeah but i i think
like the the reason ava is such an
important series to so many people
including myself is that it just hits
these emotional notes that i've just
never seen in any other piece of media
and i just i think that's because i know
i didn't give a [ __ ] about pl
and i didn't give a [ __ ] about telling a
you know a story that was easy to follow
he just wanted to like put something out
there he just wanted to put his emotions
into something and that's what i feel
from him and that's why it's so like to
so many people this is such an important
thing because it's it's rare that you
see something that isn't like that isn't
so well defined but that you can relate
to on in an emotional sense it's like
it's almost not storytelling like
arnold's not really storytelling as he
is almost just emoting i i i really
can't describe ava without sounding like
that pretentiously
right yeah you know because i hear
myself and i'm just like it's kind of
just off you know
what a wanker
it's one of those things where i i think
i
definitely would tv shows and media
as opposed to traditional art yeah i i
very much
prefer it when they essentially tell me
tell me what they're trying yeah of
course this is you know and as much as
you could argue oh okay well that's
that's for dumb people and whatnot it's
like also like well you know i feel that
if it is art i i suppose it can be but
then also
sometimes it isn't marketed as such yeah
you know like when you look at a
painting there's no doubt in your mind
that it's art and you can interpret it
however you want and yeah you get
whatever you want out of it but i think
with tv shows because it's such a
different medium it's you know what is
art supposed to be when it's tv and film
but i i would argue that some of the
best shows are the ones that can present
an artistic idea in an artistic way yeah
make it simple enough for anyone to
enjoy right like i feel that's like
really just good storytelling that's why
i think bojack horseman is amazing yeah
yeah
so i felt like it it delivered a topic
that i think a lot of people and a lot
of older people yeah don't really think
about or don't talk about yeah yeah yeah
and i think like i'm not bringing down
bojack because i also think it's an
amazing [ __ ] show um i just think
like a van gaalin was is so unique
because you know
if there's one thing that doesn't make
[ __ ] sense or you can't logically
always follow it's emotions right
sometimes you just feel something you're
just like why the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] do i
feel this like i logically don't know
why i feel this and i shouldn't feel
this and like
and like that's what ava portrays so
well it's not meant to be logical in a
lot of senses but sometimes you just see
something i'm just like i don't know why
i
kind of relate to this but i just do i
don't know why i resonate with this but
i just do and it's that's that's been my
experience with ava and i guess the
biggest thing that i never got from ava
was the satisfying conclusion of like
closure like this is it an actual ending
like this is this is it right i am
satisfied because you know we i kind of
you know as a naval fan you can find you
found your own [ __ ] closure you
watched end of favor and you're like
what the [ __ ] did i just watch i i need
someone sometimes you need someone to
help you process what you just watched
and like you know that sometimes you
spend hours
reading up analysis and reading up this
and reading up that and you're just like
end of favor is one of those movies
where like you watch it and you go that
was awesome but then the moment your
brain actually kicks in and goes but do
you know what it was about that's the
moment that's the moment where you have
like the existential adrenaline
wait maybe it wasn't good
why do you think i i didn't enjoy or
connect with
evangelion do you reckon this is why i
feel maybe it's because you were kind of
over hyped
from like the outside i i think like i
think i think
what were your expectations coming in
yeah something deep
maybe that's what it is right because
ava is like if ava is simultaneously the
deepest thing but also at the same time
something that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense yeah i mean it's not something you
watch to per se enjoy because i remember
like the only times i've actually like
actually
kind of understood ava really depended
on depended on what mindset i was in i
couldn't just yeah i i thought i was
under the impression that it was gonna
be some form of interesting take on like
being a teenager and struggling with
mental health issues it was i mean to a
certain point yeah i mean it it it is
it's just not told in a way that is just
traditional you know it's told in a very
raw [ __ ] it's taught in a very raw way
where it's just it's they don't care
about you following the story they just
wanted to like put these raw thoughts
and raw emotions put it on screen and
then just like just put it out there
that's that's what like that's what i
got from here which is why like the the
time that i connected with ava the most
just happened to be the point when i was
in the worst point in my life yes you
know it's it's just it's just
it's just something where
it's not something i think people should
watch to enjoy i think people should
watch it to experience it and maybe you
didn't enjoy this time i didn't enjoy
the first time i watched it but maybe
there would be a point when you just
like where some of the words or
something from it rang out to you and
just like
maybe this is
saying that avery is an acquired taste
no joey stop putting words in my mouth
and
what i will say about end of vavo i'm
not uh over 4.0 without spoiling what
happens because i'm not going to spoil
that experience the only thing i will
kind of say is that it is it is a
conclusive full stop yeah and i remember
because growing up i can't like i don't
know how to convey to you what it's like
growing up with a franchise and being
like this is good this franchise is
going to be around forever there is
never going to be an end for this
franchise you kind of make peace with
that right yeah because i remember when
the movie got released i think i
remember we were memeing up to be like
oh can't wait for 5.99 like 20 years
can't wait for i know to like dig up the
grave a favor and i remember like i i
talked to plenty of japanese people who
were just like no this is this is the
end i was like sure sure yeah joey go
sees it nabi gho sees it and they're
like this is the end i'm like sure
all right
it's literally uh you won't believe it
until you see it yeah yeah it is it is
and then i'll i'll watch the movies i
mean i mean
you can shoot i like i'm not like i have
like i've decided i'm going to watch are
you gonna watch that you haven't decided
when i watch the movie
where yeah i think all four movies are
on uh prime videos yeah netflix and all
of end of ava uh all of eve evangeline
the original series is on netflix and
all of the movies are on prime video so
they're easy to access